[Music]
so for you for ion it's not just
academic where do you think the bravery
comes in for you I because I can tell
there's nothing that I could possibly
ask you here that you wouldn't give me
the clearest honest answer and and that
isn't always how it is with everybody
obviously as an interviewer but where do
you think that comes from candor has
always been one of my greatest
weaknesses and I think I was probably
brought up in a rather combative family
in a rather combatted part of the world
I grew up in in Glasgow in the West of
Scotland and to a physician and a
physics that's right my mother was a
physics teacher and my father was a
doctor yeah and they were the first in
their families to go to university
my grandfather's had served in the world
wars Scots have a self image of
themselves as being courageous the
Scottish regiments were famous I wrote
about this in my one of my earliest
books the pizzi of War were famously the
sharp end of the British military we
marched towards the sound of gunfire
bagpipes playing that's the self-image
that a small Scottish boy growing up in
the nineteen sixties and seventies was
encouraged to have I remember vividly
the day that 9/11 happened I was sitting
in Oxford where I was then teaching but
planning I'd planned and was intending
to fly to New York very shortly to give
a lecture on 9/12
hmm at New York University indeed I was
booked into a hotel very close to the
World Trade Center and my response when
I saw the attacks was somewhat
bloody-minded
my response was very shortly afterwards
to resign my post at Oxford and go to
New York University and I taught there
for two years in a I suppose a mood of
defiance that the attempt to terrorize
would not terrorize me when I met
a yawn 9 more than 9 years ago now it
never crossed my mind as I fell in love
with her which happened very fast
that this implied some meaningful threat
to my person even when the FBI came to
tell me that there had been a threat
against me something that I'd seen them
do to a yharnam more than one occasion I
never gave it a second thought because
obviously my calling different from my
grandfather's who were called to fight
in real Wars my more much more
manageable calling is to is to protect
her because she's one of the great
heroines of our time an extraordinary
courageous woman who's been through a
hell of a lot and who has never shirked
from saying what she believes is wrong
with modern Islam so it it is second
nature to me to be there with her in
that in that fight in that war that's
what it turns out to beat my warm I
always used to wonder as I was growing
up why is it that my generation isn't
really been called on to fight wars the
way my grandfather's generations were
called on and then it turned up then my
war turned up you briefly mention this
earlier when you're talking about ion
and Brandeis but can you explain this
intersection of Islamism and the left
how why this has occurred this confuses
a lot of people this idea of the
oppression Olympics and you know I've
got plenty of theories on this that
we've knocked out but but what do you
think it is that has attracted something
that is completely totalitarian in
control with another thing that's so
completely to a town I mean I guess
that's the answer right there but well
there are many unholy alliances in in
history and no doubt many people were
gravely surprised when the Ribbentrop
Molotov Pat was announced and
Soviet Union and Nazi Germany formed an
alliance so we shouldn't be entirely
surprised when seemingly odd bedfellows
jump into bears in the case of the
Islamists and the left I think it's
pretty clear to me that the Islamists
are the the leading partner and the
leftists are broadly the useful idiots
because the Islamists have a strategy
it's there in Muslim Brotherhood and
other documents for expanding their
network in the West and part of the
strategy is the kind of partnership that
they have formed on campuses against
against their foes one way in which this
works is that you use the issue of
Israel to forge the pacts with the left
so you get the left's long-standing
animosity towards Zionism and you
essentially say well we entirely agree
with you about that let's let's have an
event about how wicked Israel is and so
that's the gateway drug in to accepting
the next thing is well headscarves are
actually empowering for women don't you
think
and isn't it actually Islamophobia to be
in any way critical of Sharia law so you
play the multiculturalist cultural
relativist card and you again depict any
critics of radical Islam as as in fact
engaged in some kind of Orientalist
project or essentialist project to other
people always talk about other in
academia Muslims and you blur the
distinction between Islam Islamism and
Muslims as people so this has been going
on for a while and the left has broadly
fallen for it and to me it's just
astonishing I remember looking at the
list of academics who had
who had argued that ion should not
receive an honorary degree at Brandeis
and it included professors of queer
studies female professors of Gender
Studies it's incredible you kind of feel
like saying to these people have you
taken a look at what the Muslim
Brotherhood envisages have you read cut
herbs works do you realize that the
project is the permanent demotion of
women to second-class status and
potentially capital punishment for gays
is that something you are aware of and I
can only conclude that they aren't aware
of it and have been very thoroughly
duped as useful idiots usually are so is
that basically because both of these
movements want power so the useful idiot
part of this is that the Islamists are
really just using the left to attain
power and they're doing it all in the
name of diversity and all of these
things and eventually once that power is
attained then for a lack of a better
expression I mean you basically
decapitate them and then you've got they
did it for you they did the work for you
yes I mean I always used to joke with I
on that when we lived in Cambridge it
would be fun if all my enemies and all
her enemies came and protested outside
our house together yeah because after
about 20 minutes they'd they'd fall on
one another and they would her the most
tremendous fight I do think that power
is part of it but if one looks back at
the history of another intolerant
totalitarian ideology Marxism there's a
combination of power and a kind of
idealism one must call it that in the
square and the tower I tell the story of
how the Soviets successfully penetrated
the British establishment by recruiting
spies in Cambridge and the people they
recruited had leanings to the left there
were inspired partly by revulsion at
those aspects of British imperialism or
British class Society that were in many
ways legitimately open
criticism there was an idealism there at
the beginning of guy Burgesses
involvement in Marxism sympathy with
workers during the time of the Great
Depression but those were the useful
idiots that the Soviets cynically
recruited to be spies who whom they
persuaded to betray their countrymen in
what was the single most successful act
of Russian espionage of them all
recruiting these highly educated people
from an incredibly exclusive network the
Cambridge apostles and the related
network that led to Bloomsbury this was
a brilliant strategy something similar
is going on here because I think there
are a great many naive young people who
are drawn to the rhetoric of social
justice I encounter them often people
who say oh there should be limits on
free speech because I don't want such
and such such and such as feelings to be
heard they're naive they have a very
naive view somehow there can be a
circumscribed form of free speech in
know in which nobody's feelings get hurt
that's not the pursuit of power that's
just naivety and the people who know how
to exploit that naivety are both people
amongst the Islamists and people amongst
the leftists who are pursuing power but
you can never really get to power
without the useful idiots without the
naive idealists
who think that they're going to build
utopia with your help yeah and I don't
have to tell you there usually ends up
in dystopia right so and that's that's
something that it's hard to persuade
people off yeah I keep reflecting on the
curious revival of Margaret Atwood's The
Handmaid's Tale which is always taken to
be a vision of what happens when
right-wing people take over America yeah
and to me the amazing thing that is
almost never observed is that something
very like this has happened it happened
in Iran after 1979 and it happened after
the Taliban came to power in Afghanistan
so we don't need to fantasize about
crazy evangelical fascists turning women
into baby machines this has already
happened but it was done by Islam
it was done by people pursuing an
extreme version of Sharia and yet almost
nobody who enthuses about Margaret
Atwood's book realizes that it is
actually really quite powerful
realization of what a theocratic
Islamist regime does to women all right
so I want to shift gears a little bit
here and we can either I'm gonna let you
choose we can either go the historical
route or we can go the present route
what are you feeling first I do want to
do both I think the key to applied
history which is what I've spent my
whole life doing is that you do both
alright and you can't do one without the
other because no you can have no real
insight about the present without the
past so why don't we talk about the
present and I'll try to show why to
understand it you need history all right
very good so there are a couple things
that are interesting that you've staked
out positions on over the past couple
years we briefly right before we sat
down we talked about Bragg's it for a
second so you originally were for we're
against Bragg's is yeah then you came
around for it now it seems to be in this
odd limbo that I think unfortunately
most people in America don't even
understand what's what's going I do
think most people in Britain on but I'm
sure so when I was reading your position
on this at first I thought well wait a
minute as a conservative and as someone
that wants some autonomy over his
country I was somewhat surprised
actually that you weren't for it
originally so can you explain your
original position and then how you
changed on that there were two reasons
why I was on the side of remain remain
in the EU back in 2016 one was pure
personal loyalty to friends David
Cameron was Prime Minister George
Osborne was Chancellor of the Exchequer
and they are friends of mine and I I
felt obliged as a friend to support them
when they decided to stick with the EU
and not to recommend brexit did that
friendship supersede what your feelings
were or was that because you really
trusted that they could get into
anything that swung it okay and I think
the reason that I was willing to get on
board with remain was that I found that
arguments of the brexit ears deeply on
convincing I remember one night sitting
down and reading a lot of stuff by
Daniel Hannan one of the leading
advocates of of leaving and I remember
thinking that this was just
intellectually completely third-class
and unconvincing the notion that Britain
would be better off economically outside
the European Union wouldn't have passed
muster as an undergraduate paper never
mind a graduate of paper so I felt that
the brexit ia's case failed
intellectually because they were
claiming implausibly i thought that you
could have a free lunch that you could
leave the european union and be better
off and that just seemed to me to be
intellectually completely deceitful I
think it would have been harder for me
if they had said honestly this is going
to cost quite a bit but it's worth it
because if we leave then we shall have
the ability to control our borders and
we shall have autonomy at a time when
Europe is pursuing a Federalists course
but that wasn't the argument the
argument was that not the area because
that we're going to get the money
a hearse was the argument I'm going to
get the money that we give to the
European Union and we'll get bill to
spend on the National Health Service
because we will be in fact better off
and that was a lie and I'm not good with
lies it was a clever lie it worked
politically and I give credit to Dominic
Cummings for crafting a message that was
appealing both to conservatives and to
labour voters the Conservatives got
immigration control labor voters got the
National Health Service gets the money
so this is brilliant politically but it
was mendacious I think during that part
and so I I opposed the brexit when it
happened
what struck me in the subsequent months
was that while I had been while I had
been on the side that lost there was a
good reason why we lost and the good
reason was that we went around saying
how much it was going to cost
and I think we were right about that I
think ultimately at least some of what
the Treasury said will true will turn
out to be true about the cost but that
wasn't what people cared about mm-hmm
and when you went into pubs as I did in
Wales in England and in Scotland there
was a question to which you could not
give an honest answer without losing the
debate and I'll tell you what that
question was because I was asked it
multiple times you'd make the case about
the cost nobody was interested in the
cost they would say listen Neil about
the 1.3 million Muslims the Germans have
just let in to Germany because that had
just happened mm-hmm if the Germans give
them German passports can they come here
and the only honest answers of that
question was yes so immigration was the
issue and I think for a significant
number of people in England and Wales
especially was less so in Scotland where
brexit was defeated the realization was
that Britain had lost control of
immigration the people had been promised
net migration in the tens of thousands
and in the 1990s under the Blair
government and they'd ended up with net
migration in the hundreds of thousands
they saw the chaos in Germany they saw
the waves of migration coming on only
from Syria but from all over North
Africa and and even South Asia and they
said and I remember David Cameron using
this phrase get me out of here and that
was that was the driving motivation for
the brexit vote and I think it was
legitimate because I think that Angela
Merkel had made a catastrophic mistake
in throwing open the gates I think it
will have dire consequences for the
future of Germany and of Europe and I do
not blame British voters for saying
forget about the cost of brexit we
really need to get out of this so I take
took the view by the end of 2016 that
you had to you had to respect the fact
that ordinary people had cut through the
crap of the debate and it got to the
heart of the matter and the heart of the
matter wasn't the cost of braixen
which is what I had I think mistakenly
focused on prior to the referendum what
was it like for you as a public person
and you know some of the rights about
this stuff and puts your opinions out
there that to have that realization I
think it's very important if you write
regularly if you are what we call a
public intellectual to be willing to
admit that you've been wrong I think you
have to be prepared to say I was wrong
and I think I was wrong in the sense
that what I wish I had done looking back
was I wish I had said to David Cameron
George Osborne in the spring of 2016
when it was clear that the Europeans
were going to make no meaningful
concession on the immigration issue when
they basically sent an insulting
proposal about what could be done about
migration that was the moment I should
have said to Cameron Osbourne forget it
yeah you should campaign for brexit if
that's all they're going to offer you if
they're so completely oblivious to the
very real concerns about immigration
then you should campaign for brakes
instead of which we stuck with it and
that was that was David Cameron's great
mistake he should have said at that
moment if that's all you've got
I'm going to recommend breaks it to the
voters and it would have saved him too
so so you think it was just a bad
negotiating ploy that he just didn't use
some leverage to say we're gonna have to
walk away from this there was there was
a moment when he should have walked away
and I should have advised him to walk
away so yeah I think one has to
recognize when one's made a mistake with
such consequences the second thing which
is worth knowing about this is that the
people who then inherited power after
the fall of Cameron at nas born were not
the people who had campaigned for and
one on rancid it was people who'd been
on the remain side Theresa May became
Prime Minister I always knew that would
be a disaster I did not have high regard
for her prior to the referendum the
Daily Mail essentially put her in that
position and also Boris Johnson Michael
Gove and others because they bungled the
leadership contest so
we then ended up with the terrible
combination which was a commitment to
breaks it but its execution in the hands
of people who had been remain errs and I
think the result is the worst of both
worlds because right now we essentially
have the psychological reality of brexit
I think British public to a large extent
has accepted that we are leaving
but the executions are total mess yeah
by invoking article 50 early on the UK
and essentially ceded the the power in
the divorce to the European Union and
the concessions have come one after
another ever since then and we now find
ourselves in the odd predicament that I
think Theresa May is saying that brexit
means
you cease to be a voting member of the
European Union but you remain within the
customs union potentially even within
the single market and you accept all the
rules and regulations of the European
Union you just don't have any power if
that's the end game yeah
then it's a disaster so the people that
are trying to stop this now they want to
invoke some some pretty crazy extreme
stuff right I mean there would be some
really very rarely if ever used rules am
i right about this that would actually
allow this to allow the state to occur
well listen I think those games without
getting into all of them I think that
there is a level of complexity in the
discussions now in London that is
bewildering to most ordinary British
people when people start talking about
max FAC and the customs union complex
confusing way because I discuss it with
Douglas Murray and he was even a little
confused it's actually not confusing in
the sense that what is happening is that
Theresa May is trying to get Britain to
accept the realities of belonging to the
European customs union which would
preclude Britain having its own trade
policy with our leaving the European
Union's decision-making body so
essentially in that version breaks it is
just you have the responsibilities you
just don't have any power anymore which
is definitely not what the British
public was told and it was getting in in
brexit
the bigger problem in my mind is is not
one that that we've discussed and that
is that all of this will end in tears to
the point at which Jeremy Corbyn the
most left-wing leader the Labour Party
has ever had in its history becomes
Prime Minister because Theresa May is
leading the country towards this very
unhappy compromise at some point the
people who truly believe in brexit Jacob
Riis MOG for example perhaps Michael
Gove they may decide we can't ultimately
accept this and the government may fall
but the problem is that if the
government Falls then Jeremy Corbyn is
Prime Minister if the government doesn't
fall and we go all the way to the
finishing line with this Theresa May
version of brexit then I think the
Conservatives will lose the next
election in 2022 and Jeremy Coleman will
be Prime Minister so the worst they are
about Greg's it is in my view that if it
is bungled in this way it will open the
door to a truly leftist government and
that will be far more economically
damaging then anything Briggs it has
done and that's the nightmare scenario
for me and probably socially damaging
and fever zillion other reasons deeply I
should be extremely suspicious of
Colburn and his people they are
committed Marxists they've been on the
wrong side of every issue in my lifetime
with a possible exception of South
African apartheid and I do not trust
them with the keys to 10 Downing Street
because I think that their ultimate
agenda is a truly revolutionary one and
it poses a threat to the fundamental
liberties the traditions of the
Constitution it's a dangerous dangerous
prospect and I'm much more worried about
kolben that about brings it I mean this
is how I feel about what's happening
with our left in America talking about
you you guys are giving us basically the
precursor to this I think one of the
lessons of history and now we can bring
history in is that with populism you you
get two flavours in a typical backlash
that would come after a financial crisis
the political establishments discredited
there's a backlash against inequality
all of the things that typically follow
are financial crisis but there are two
possibilities
there's the populism of the left which
is the tax the rich solution but the
populism of the right is more potent
because it says it's a bad immigration
it's about globalization it's about free
trade mm-hmm
and so broadly speaking there's a very
good study that shows this after a big
financial crises the populace of the
right do better because they offer a
more plausible story but if they don't
deliver when they generally don't
because quite hard to make immigration
control and tariffs pay that's quite
hard actually to make your constituents
better off at those policies then the
pendulum has a tendency to swing to the
populism of the left and that has
happened in Britain really quickly
because Corbin became popular very soon
after breaks it it's slower here but the
fear must be that if the Trump
experiment goes as wrong as the vast
majority of intellectuals expect it to
the pendulum will swing to the the left
of the Democratic Party and that
scenario seems to me more and more
plausible and I don't think that's a
that's of not unappetizing yeah I mean
that that's genuinely scary to me but I
want to back up for one second because
the moment that you had that you said a
few times happened in these pubs when
you would go there and people would say
this about 1.3 million Muslims in in
Germany how do you so okay so that if
you were listening to the mainstream
media they would say these people are
all racist that's what they would tell
you they're they're racists and they're
bigots I suspect that's not what you
think of these people although there
probably was a certain amount of people
that are just racist and don't like
people of a different color or a
different culture how do you even have
that conversation because that's what so
much of this is about because you I'm
sure would have a pint with these people
and you talk to them and realize that
they weren't racist they were actually
just worried about their future which is
legit but if you can't have that
discussion because every time you open
your mouth they tell you you're racist
well then we know what you end up with
look I would be very strange if I took a
bigoted view on this subject because I'm
an immigrant I'm in fact about to become
an American citizen in a matter of weeks
my wife was a refugee who got from
Somalia originally to the Netherlands by
applying for asylum mm-hmm and so we
would be the last couple to take a kind
of bigoted view on the immigration issue
because we're the grits when I had
conversations on this subject at the
time of the brexit referendum I remember
realizing that the opposition to
immigration was not plausibly a racist
because and remember somebody making the
point that he was as worried about the
people from Lithuania and Poland coming
to Britain as he was about people from
Syria and Iraq and you probably know
that people from Poland in Lithuania are
pretty wise great so here's the thing
what we all read to recognize is that if
immigration shoots up if it grows from
in the case of Britain 10,000 or 20,000
a year to 200,000 or 300,000 a year
perfectly unprejudiced people will say
that's too much this is going too fast
and that I think was the dominant
argument of course there are people who
are racists in any society but the
striking thing about Britain is actually
that it's not a terribly racist place
did you see many people protesting
against Prince Harry's decision to marry
an American of mixed-race I was there a
couple days before the bull very exactly
were huge crowds this match is
extraordinary popular with ordinary
people so I think it's hard to argue
that racism played any meaning
part the white supremacist elements in
Britain is really is really very
insignificant and actually one of the
ways in which the British like to define
themselves is as being tolerant memories
of the war of not entirely faded even as
the wartime generation gradually
disappears from the scene what was the
war against Germany about it was a war
against the ultimate racist state what
hurt Jeremy Corbyn the most in the last
three or four months the evidence that
there are anti-semitic elements within
his faction of the labor left that hurt
him and it's important that that
argument keep being made because it has
real truth to it and I think all the way
people think that's not good so I think
this is not really about racism it's not
about bigotry it's about how rapidly
should immigration occur how large
should flows be across borders and the
lesson of history is that if you allow a
real surge in immigration there will be
a populist backlash against what
happened in the United States in the
late 19th century at the peak in the
1880s the foreign-born percentage of the
population in the u.s. was about 14% it
had gone up from relatively low levels
about 14% same thing has happened in our
time it was down I think below 7% in the
mid 20th century and the period after
World War Two immigrants were a
relatively small proportion late
foreign-born citizens of a pretty small
portion of the US population and then
from the 1980s onwards the proportion
surged and the character of the
immigrants changed
that the places that they came from
changed and these changes are bound to
elicit a reaction it always happens and
it's not enough for people in the
liberal elites who by and large don't
live in areas where immigrants come to
say what a terrible deplorable bunch of
chauvinists you are for not wanting for
not wanting more immigrants
that's simply that's simply historically
stupid and the other thing that's stupid
about this in the United States is the
people on the Left who want to
legitimize
illegal immigration now I think for many
people who were attracted to Trump the
issue was the illegal quality of the
immigration the rule of law is a big
deal now in the english-speaking world
and people don't like to hear anything
that simply says amnesty for lawbreakers
if you're a law-abiding citizen and
you're suddenly told well yeah the law
applies to you but there are these other
people it's not going to apply to you
then your natural reaction is screw this
that's why I thought one of his best
lines he doesn't use it as much anymore
but during the campaign we're either a
country or were not I thought was a
really effective line you either have
laws or you don't I mean that in essence
is the truth so let's shift to Trump a
little bit here I think that we're kind
of in a similar spot with him which is
that it's better than the alternative
that that's certainly how I feel at this
point that all of the forces that we've
spent the last hour plus talking about
would be that much more emboldened
against free thought and all and free
expression and open inquiry and all the
things that we care about and an
historical fact and and everything else
if he wasn't president right now I am
deeply ambivalent about all of this I
think it's it's very very hard to say a
good word about the personality of
Donald Trump I'm with you it was a
reason that I found it impossible to
support him in 2016 I think one has to
acknowledge that he has used
inflammatory language on the issues
we've talked about immigration that he
has a record of lying which is even by
the standards of American presidents
pretty remarkable and so the familiar
list of things about Donald Trump that
most of my friends find objectionable is
kind of hard for me to to dismiss
but I said I'm bivolo for a reason on
the other hand number one what if he'd
lost I said this to Sam Harris a few
weeks ago let's run the counterfactual
this is what historians should do let's
imagine an alternative history if don't
firm had lost the election by let's say
the same narrow margin that he won it
how would all those people who voted for
him have felt and how would they have
behaved so my mind the election of
Donald Trump is a cathartic moment for
those people so despised by the liberal
elites that they could refer to them as
deplorable
the people who voted for Donald Trump
are not by and large racists are not by
and large anything like Donald Trump is
personally what attracted them to Trump
were two things which as with the brexit
campaign were legitimate number one they
were attracted to Trump's policy
positions on trade on immigration on
Islam and on the somewhat a corrupt
liberal elite that had been running the
country for the previous eight years so
I think they were attracted to Trump's
policy positions but they were also
attracted to his cultural position and I
think about half of American populism is
cultural what attracted the friends I
have who supported Trump to Trump was
his fundamental shift in language away
from the politically correct talking
points of the political class
Republicans and Democrats alike to a
domotic normal way of speaking such as
you would hear in the typical American
are more or less anywhere in the country
except Cambridge Massachusetts Stanford
California and the rest now I I remember
thinking on the eve of the election if
you'd line up all the people who are
going to vote for her and you line up
all the people who are going to vote for
him which line would you rather be in
remember at that point I'm not a citizen
I don't know
and I thought that's easy I'm with the
people who are so pissed with the
political establishment that they are
ready to take a chance on this guy
because they see no other way to shake
things up the way my friend Jerry Blake
put it to me
ex-marine core ex-nypd never when a
college helps take care of my wife's
security Jerry said to me early 2016
two things that stuck in my mind first
he told me John was gonna win but then
he said the two reasons why he supported
from number one he tells it like it is
number two he's gonna shake things up
why he tells it like it is Jerry did not
mean he is always truthful what he meant
was he talks like me by shaking things
up Jerry meant we have to do something
because this system as it stands is not
in my interests it's not a my interest
economically because it seems to favor
China over the United States Mexicans
over native-born Americans the rich 1%
over me the median household but he's
also it's also about this cultural
reaction against the multiculturalism
that has become the orthodoxy of the
liberal left so for all my reservations
about Trump I completely got why people
voted for him and I think their reaction
had he lost would have been toxic I
don't think they would have accepted the
legitimacy of the result I think they
would have bought the story Trump would
have told them that the election had
been rigged and I think we would have
had a poisoned body politic from day one
of a Pinsent presidency if it all ends
oddly though were having that right now
just in the reverse all right it would
have been worse but we're having a left
that's not accepting the legitimacy of
the election and I think it would have
been worse yeah I think it would have
been worse
and I think and this is another part of
the story that for Jerry and his and his
many many fellow Americans who voted
Trump this has always been a guy
and they've always had a sense that it
could go wrong you know when you shake
things up but sometimes they break
mm-hmm
a nice I sense that if it all ends in
Fiasco which I guess the vast majority
of public intellectuals expect and some
combination of Watergate and other
scandals I think Jerry and his and his
fellow American Trump supporters all say
well we gave it a try give it a try and
I think that's that's one possible
scenario the other reason that I I'm
ambivalent about Trump is that for all
his flaws in some ways he's doing a
better job on foreign policy than his
predecessor did because Trump has this
superpower that most intellectuals can
understand he has an unerring instinct
for the weakness of the counterparty
it's a kind of almost animal instinct
but somehow Donald Trump can tell when
the other side is weak he could see it
in Jeb Bush you could see it Marco Rubio
could see it Hillary Clinton and now I
think he sees it in the Europeans he
sees an Angela Merkel you don't pay
enough for your defense what if I walk
out on NATO yeah Kim jong-un he sees it
in Xi Jinping he sees it in the in the
supreme leader in Iran
so my ambivalence is partly my sympathy
for Trump supporters Mike my fundamental
sense of why they voted for him but it's
also that in some ways this disruption
has its plus site in the way that it's
repositioning the United States I mean I
to me it's given oxygen to everything
that we've talked about here and that
doesn't that doesn't discount all of the
legitimate concerns that you look the
big concern for me as I mentioned before
is that the pendulum swings the other
way if this all ends in teers all of
those who defended it even if they
defended it half-heartedly like me will
be describes it mm-hmm
and the damage will be irreparable for
conservatives and populist Szalai the
left will be empowered and they will
spend the rest of our lives telling us
that we were apologists for the worst
president and that's that
not a scenario that you can discount
likely for a time I think it was
exhilarating our freely admit that for
me one of the most satisfying aspects of
Trump's victory was that all the people
I most disliked in this contract we're
in a state of hysteria and shock for
weeks and I remember saying that I
aren't you know it can't be all bad if
the people I really can't stand are in
this state but you have to I think with
history and mind be conscious of the
dangers of the fact that this could end
yeah so badly that it does irreparable
damage and and the worst damage of all
will be if it propels the left of the
Democratic Party into power and that you
can't rule out you can't really the
worst thing about studying history is
that it makes you aware of how
undetermined istic the historical
process is that there is always more
than one future there's the future of
triumph there's the future of tragedy
and there's this kind of other future in
the middle which is a little bit of both
and that's really why the historical
moment is bad for restful sleep one
wakes up in the morning and I'm sure you
have the same feeling
wondering what alert will be on your
phone and what message will be on your
phone
well the alerts say Wars broken out will
the alert say our palace coup and will
the message say your reputation has just
been been destroyed by some accusation
or other so one wakes up in a state of
anxiety in the United States of 2018 and
that is a reality that I think is
inherent in both the culture war that
we've spoken about and the Trump
presidency which is in some measure a
backlash against that that culture war
we're gonna leave it at that but I am
going to demand that you come back I
don't think I've ever demanded that I
guess I can ask but I'm legitimately
demanding that you come back because
next time I want to do I want to just do
all history and we try to even barely
jump into I won't have any prior stuff
and Churchill and I okay I'm demanding
it will you accept my demand I accept
all right it took a long time to get
here but but considering we're both two
guys just off planes today you're you're
like 37 hours out of whack the jet lag
the things we said will be taken out of
context on Twitter well I sincerely hope
everything because the whole thing goes
this has truly truly been an absolute
pleasure and thank you for doing this
and send my best of course
Ayana sure will and for more on Neil you
can follow him on the Twitter although
you don't fight with people that much on
Twitter which means you're of strong
moral character I I decided the jungle
warfare was not the way to go he's a
wise man and it's @n f e RG u s
[Music]